une immense banderole exprime la
frustration et l'exaspération des
riverains côté loire l'endroit est
paisible la rue calme et bordée de
pavillons le permis de construire
important sans ambiguïté en lieu et
place de cette maison sera érigé un
immeuble de trois étages et 21
appartements une verrue qui va défigurer
selon les riverains un patrimoine classé
est ce qu'on voit c'est un paysage ici
boisé verdoyant des maisons
individuelles et donc on sort de la
ville l'urbanisation pour petit à petit
prendre sa respiration est allé au fur
et à mesure dans la vallée des rois
donc on a quelque chose qui est à
sauvegarder mais au delà de nos intérêts
personnels
il ya les intérêts du paysage de la
région et patrimoine de l'ue et du
patrimoine de l'unesco
autre grief l'absence de concertation
pour un projet si ambitieux alors les
habitants rencontrés les élus le
promoteur et le cabinet d'architecturé
avec une liste de réclamation
cet immeuble prévu pourrait
éventuellement un petit peu s'insérer
dans le cadre si les témoins ou voyez je
veux dire on n'est pas gourmand
au départ on disait non complètement si
on peut pas faire autrement au moins
limiter les dégâts ensuite j'avais
effectivement bon si on pouvait limiter
les accès dans la rue si on pouvait
faire un petit décrochage pour le les
bacs à poubelles des miettes
la dernière proposition qu'on a eus y
aurait moins d'ouvertures à l'ouest
c'est à dire chez nous parce que nous on
sera plus chez nous dans nos jardins
par contre il y aurait des terrasses
immense au dernier étage les dés sont
jetés le projet conforme au plan local
d'urbanisme
alors les riverains prennent leur mal en
patience ils ont déposé un recours